hola buenos días la pandemia la
generación de trabajos la economía la
corte suprema fueron algunos de los
temas en común durante esos dos tangos
en los cuales participaron donald trump
y joe wright en el caso de donaldson se
vio un cambio en su postura frente a los
resultados de las elecciones dijo que si
llega a perder daría una transición
pacífica de poder a su ganador algo que
no había hecho anteriormente también
condenó el supremacismo blanco en el
caso de joe baird dijo que dará a
conocer su posición clara sobre si
llegaría a ampliar o no la corte suprema
si llega a ser presidente de los eeuu y
dijo que daría esta respuesta antes de
las elecciones el próximo 3 de noviembre
también dijo que echaría atrás los
decretos del presidente de donald trump
que discriminan a las personas
transexuales bailén dijo que está
dispuesto a debatir de nuevo al
presidente de lyon la próxima semana
pero él
mandatario en ocasiones anteriores ha
dicho que no lo haría aunque es muy
posible todavía quedan dos semanas en
que se puedan volver a enfrentar